every night countless people wake up
unable to move their minds and bodies in
the throes of a real condition called
sleep paralysis when triggered the
symptoms are usually mild from tense
muscles to labored breathing
but for some the experience conjures
hallucinations that make nightmares come
alive here are some of their stories
[Music]
before I learned to cope with it I've
seen quite a few awful things horror
films don't really don't really do
anything for me anymore because what
I've seen is more terrifying the
earliest I can remember is seeing a
figure that looked like my mother
sitting on my bed her face is then
morphing into some kind of demon another
time a little girl was in the corner
just just staring at me
then without notice she shrieks and runs
up and grabs me by the neck
you're trying to call for help but your
voice it it doesn't work and your body
won't respond you just you just you just
feel helpless on one particular night I
felt like someone was looking at me from
the foot of my bed I knew that nothing
was there but I was afraid to open my
eyes when I did I saw a woman's head
looking straight back at me she didn't
have a body or even a neck just her head
I still remember the smirk she had on
her face I closed my eyes immediately
and I was unable to move when I felt it
was safe I opened my eyes again
[Music]
she was still there and she began to
laugh at me I closed my eyes again
hoping she would disappear then I heard
this scoff and she was gone so I
remember waking up and feeling a
presence in the room and I see this
woman in a black dress looming above the
floor and she kept coming closer and
closer to me I could feel my throat
closing I I couldn't breathe as soon as
she made it towards me she floated right
in front of my face and started
screaming I bolted out of my bed and I
tried to wake up my parents little did I
know I was still dreaming and I ended up
back in my bed in another sleep
paralysis experience it's something that
it's so wild and surreal that there's no
logic to it so if you wake up one day
paralyzed by horrific visions remember
to stay calm and understand that your
nightmares are only as real as you make
them
[Music]
you